welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka the man of
spoils aka the death knight AKA these
puns get worse and worse every video
with crisis on Infinite Earths knocking
out of the park this week it to you -
it's awesome finale DC fans are now
looking to the future to see what's in
store for the universe throughout this
video we'll be breaking down all of the
upcoming DC comic book movies and
discussing their release dates and what
we can expect there's gonna be some
spoilers here in regards to a crisis on
Infinite Earths cameo the birds of prey
and Wonder Woman plot leaks as well as
behind-the-scenes shots of the Batman so
if you don't want anything potentially
ruined about some of these movies then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
if you're still here make sure you
subscribe to the channel for more
breakdowns like this every day
and without the way I just want to give
a huge thank you for clicking this video
now let's get into our breakdown of the
upcoming DC slate
okay so first up is birds of prey or to
give it its full title birds of prey in
the fantabulous Emancipation of one
Holly Quinn you had to ruin my YouTube
tags didn't you DC you idiots anyway the
film is due to be released on February
the 7th and with it being less than a
month away there's actually quite a lot
that we know about the movie Margot
Robbie will once more be reprising her
role as Harley Quinn and she'll be
teaming up with Mary Elizabeth Winston's
Huntress Rosie Perez detective Renee
Montoya and jurnee smollett Belle is
Black Canary according to the leaks the
film is going to send her around a young
Cassandra Cain stealing a sex tape from
Black Mask and after he often said she
goes looking for help
this puts her on a path with a newly
single Quinn and together they team up
with other people that mask is wrong in
order to take him down whether this
movie is any good we don't know yet but
there are rumors that this film will
kill off Jared Leto's Joker so DC can
bring across Joaquin Phoenix's version
of the character to the main universe we
will find out in less than a month but
this film is going to kickstart the 20s
on either the right or wrong foot for DC
after this comes Wonder Woman 1984 which
is due to be released on June the 5th
Diana Prince aka Wonder Woman is
arguably the DCE use most popular
character at this point and even the
underperformance of Batman V Superman
couldn't stop gal gadot from shining in
the role after the success of the first
movie the patty Jenkins directed film
has been fast-tracked and it's going to
take place in the 80s during the final
days of the Cold War Pedro Pascal is
playing Maxwell Lord and according to
the leaks he Commission's Kristen wicks
character Barbara Minerva to search for
a mystical stone that makes wishes come
true Minerva finds it and wishes to
become a superhero and this transforms
her into the villain the cheetah angered
out Lord she goes on a mission to kill
him but he hires Wonder Woman
saying that in exchange for a protection
he'll grant her one wish which she uses
to resurrect Steve Trevor almost said
Steve Rogers there thank God for edit in
any way due to the phenomenal trailer
Wonder Woman 84 is building a lot of
hype around it and it could assure in a
new era for the DC characters after this
DC have over a year-long hiatus before
we get the Batman which is going to
release on June the 25th 2021 Ben
Affleck was originally signed on to
write and direct the project but after
things fell apart Warner Bros decided to
bring Matt Reeves to oversee the project
and he went in a different direction
casting Robert Pattinson as the Dark
Knight the film is currently shooting in
the UK right now and over the last
couple of weeks we've had behind the
scenes photos that show Pattinson as
well as Colin Farrell is the Gotham
crime boss the penguin
Jeffrey Wright is playing Commissioner
Gordon and zoe kravitz is playing the
role of Selina Kyle the movie is
reportedly going to be following the
story of the long Halloween and there
are rumors that we will be seeing both a
bat suit and batten Biel very very soon
as the film issuing exterior night
scenes on the streets of Glasgow right
now a massively hyped for the movie and
out of the lineup this is the one that
I'm looking forward to the most after
this comes the Suicide Squad
after James Gunn was fired by Disney DC
quickly snapped him up and though he has
signed back on with Marvel to direct
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 he is very
much putting all of his efforts into
this follow up the first Suicide Squad
underperformed and Gunn is hopefully
going to breathe life back into the
franchise with the wealth of character
margot robbie will return as Holly Quinn
Joel Kinnaman is back as Rick Flagg GI
Courtney is returning his Captain
Boomerang and Viola Davis will be
overseeing the mission as Amanda Waller
there's also a lot of new names heading
up the project such as John Cena Idris
Elba Nathan Fillion and Michael Rooker
and all in all it seems like it's gonna
be a great film when it releases on
August 6 2021 now just when you think
2021 couldn't get any more packed Dwayne
the rock Johnson will finally be making
his debut in the DC Universe as Black
Adam on December 22nd of 2021 the
character was supposed to debut in
Shazam and there was a little nod to him
but the studio decided to save his entry
for a solo movie instead of the usual
Vilna he's often portrayed as black Adam
will be more of an antihero and
apparently the film will be introducing
the Justice Society of America so make
sure you stay locked to the channel for
more information on this project as we
get it 2022 truly begins for the DC EU
on April Fool's Day with Shazam 2
dropping on April 1st
Shazam was a big turning point for the
DC u and though Aquaman and Wonder Woman
were extremely successful this showed
that the DC team could make a comedy
instead of sitting in the dark demeanor
that they tended to we don't know much
about the castor plot but it is assumed
that a lot of the characters will return
here with potential for Black Adam and
the character to go head-to-head
after this DC are dropping a more
kid-friendly movie with the release of
DC Super Pets on May 20th 2022 this
animated adventure is set to follow
Krypto the Superdog ace the bat-hound
and many more as they tell tales from
the DC EU it's a big leap for the
company and now it probably won't be
part of the main continuity it does show
that they are trying new things
following this is the flash which is due
to hit cinemas on July 1st 2022 Ezra
Miller is back as the Scarlet speedster
and Andy machete is confirmed that this
will be a flashpoint based film that is
reportedly going to shift Ben Affleck's
Batman out of continuity and bring
Pattinson xin ezra made a big cameo on
crisis and it's great to see that the
actor is still going ahead with what has
been a very
delay project 2022 ends with Aquaman 2
which is due to be released on December
16th this is one of the most anticipated
DC movies in development and after the
first film grossed 1.14 billion it's
easy to see why James 1 is back in the
director's chair and all of the main
players including mirror ohm and Black
Manta are set to be returning we don't
know much about the film but expect an
underwater adventure that builds on a
lot of the plot points of the first
movie up next to other movies and
development now we do know about but
just don't have a specific date for
firstly a Batgirl film has been on the
slate for a while after Joss Whedon
stated he'd be interesting and bringing
the character to the big screen Whedon
reportedly wanted to adapt a
million-dollar debut Batgirl but he
stated that he couldn't make it work
though he left the project Warner Bros
are still pushing ahead and apparently
looking for a female director to take
the helm the script is currently being
penned by the birds of prey writer and
it does look like this is going ahead
Green Lantern Corps is also do a film
and it was announced in 2011 that Warner
Bros were working on a film centered
around the group this movie was stated
to have a July 2020 release but as we
know it currently isn't in production
however there are rumors that the
project will be moving to the new HBO
streaming service and after a teaser in
the latest episode of crisis it does
seem like things are in the works
whether this will be a movie that
launches on the platform or a TV show we
don't know yet but I thought I'd include
it on this list just in case Justice
League dark is also apparently close to
getting off the ground with guillermo
del toro and doug liman both being
attached the film this was originally
titled dark universe but after they ran
into problems with Universal it was
changed to Justice League dark WB are
actively trying to get this made and I
don't think it'll be too long until we
get an official announcement from the
studio in addition to this New Gods is
set to be directed by Ava Duvernay
who is also going to be penning the
script with Tom King Darkseid will be
the primary villain and after his big
entrance didn't happen in Justice League
this will be his first appearance the
trench also got added to DC's slate
within the last year and they
Aquaman's spinoff is gone to center
around the suit of Land Before Time
aesthetic that the location provided it
won't tie into the main DC timeline but
there's still a lot of potential here
for interesting part elements on top of
this we also have rumors of a Nightwing
Chris McKay movie as well as a Supergirl
film from 22 Jump Street writer or a new
Zell Gotham City sirens is being headed
up by David Ayer Holly Quinn is also
getting a solo movie and apparently a
cyborg film is still on the card
starring ray Fisher Black Hawk is still
being worked on by Steven Spielberg and
who knows we may even get a Batman with
Joker movie at some point down the line
the slate is filled to the brim and if
you thought the last decade was good for
comic book movies then you haven't seen
anything yet there's a lot of potential
ahead and there's never been a better
time to be a DC fan they're definitely
in a position at the moment where if
they play their cards right they could
really rival Marvel and it's gonna be an
awesome decade for fans of both now
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on the lineup and which movie out of the
bunch that you're most excited for
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up make sure you check out our
breakdown of the full crisis and
infinite's crossover finale which is
gonna be linked at the end we go over
all of the big cameos easter eggs and
more so it's definitely worth checking
out if you want to know more you can
support the show by subscribing to us on
patreon and if you want to come chat to
us after the video then join our discord
server in the description below or
follow us on twitter at definition
whitey that's the best way to keep up to
date with everything at heavy spoilers
and hopefully we see you over there very
soon but also just want to let you know
we're giving away a free copy of dr.
sleep to one random subscriber all you
have to do to be in with a chance of
winning is like the video subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
the slay in the comments section below
the winners gonna be chosen at random on
the 15th of February and the cell be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
prize so best of luck to everyone who
takes part this is a channel for people
who are super into superheroes so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thank you for taking the time
to watch this I've been definition that
you've been the best
see you next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you